so the president called a meeting with
sydney powell and rudy giuliani amongst
others to discuss sidney powell becoming
special counsel to the white house
in charge of election fraud also at the
meeting they discussed
issuing executive order to seize voting
machines and potentially using the
military to i guess redo the election so
the president is in full leroy jenkins
mode but there's good news and bad news
about
sydney powell as special counsel number
one this may or may not be a muller-type
special counsel it may just be a
post created at the white house and as
bonkers as that is national security
councilor kel mcclanahan who's also the
lawyer for legal eagle points out that
basically zero oversight foia wouldn't
apply until 2025 if they don't destroy
the records on the way out but if she
got a security clearance she'd have to
go through the same pre-publication
review that john bolton did
so merry christmas everyone but if you'd
like some real holiday cheer check out
this video i did on all the laws broken
in national lampoon's christmas vacation
and i'll see you in court